a reassuring wipe of her son's cheek and
Kate introduced Prince George to the
southern hemisphere
concentrating on carrying her
eight-month-old down the steps the
windswept Duchess also had to contend
with the weather
Prince George by comparison appeared
unfazed seemingly eager to meet his
first foreign prime minister as this
historic royal tour finally got underway
fidgeting in his mother's arms
It was as if the third in line to the
throne was keen to get going
a reassuring tap from dad Prince William
and then facing forward Prince George's
first overseas royal wave to those of
this far away British realm following
close behind the family of three an
entourage of many private secretaries
police protection officers and of course
Prince George's new nanny
Maria Burrell Oh
but it was the Australian media hours
before who'd spoilt the carefully
choreographed start to this tour cameras
capturing the royal family in the Sydney
Airport transit area before boarding the
Royal New Zealand Air Force flight to
Wellington theas intimidating a
traditional Maori warrior welcome for
the royal couple at Government House in
Wellington designed to work out whether
the British visitors were Friend or Foe
it was left to the Duke to stare out his
host was perhaps a good thing that by
now Prince George was safely hidden away
with his nanny William and Kate will
operate a hub based tour which means
they'll travel in and out of cities in
Australia and New Zealand to minimize
the impact on their son night away from
him kept to a minimum but they also know
they have to manage his introduction to
two countries where one day he will be
king this tour will focus heavily on
Prince George and so there was a flurry
of excitement as a baby appeared at the
window of Government House but George it
was not instead maybe a playmate for the
toddler for the duration of his stay
William Kate and George will disappear
from view for the next 24 hours
as they catch up on a little sleep and
prepare for the young prince's first
public engagement here on Wednesday Paul
Harrison Sky News New Zealand